we have 20 penguins in here these are
found off the coast of South Africa and
Namibia so designing this particular
habitat and all penguin habitat so you
first take a look at how many outs you
want to have as an
number you also take a look at how much
food you be feeding them to make sure
that the water can adequately can
the amount of what
that they're going to produce so you
make sure you get all the life support
available for the number of birds to our
Nessus that are necessary or that you
want to be able to keep what went into
it like technology behind
like it looks like the lights or
marriages and it kind of looks like two
white lights and a black light in
between I don't want to look at them
because they're so bright we had went
there's a lot of research came up with
what the spectrum lighting that they
should be having the UV minimum UV the
biblical term exactly what kind of
length of daylight that should be having
and we have sunrise sunset in here we
have a romantic kind of me if you like
I'm kind of effective
remember it's just completely dark and
that changes throughout the year it's
all computer driven in terms of our air
handling it's laboratory quality and it
changes throughout get it we change of
temperature up there water quality we've
got ozone we've got sand filters with
bile towers we've got everything to have
the best water quality it seems you're
down like they're really happy but
there's no we're looking at a sort of
empty ticket hall that's extremely going
to be filled with people including like
snotty bratty little kids who are going
to bang
how are they going to respond to that I
mean where they're like tests did you
bring in and like a bunch of brats and
like see how they'd elevator we have had
some of these birds for 25 years of the
left so our 25-year old we've had four
total five years so he has had children
and even adults hitting the glass the
whole time what's great is that we've
got the distance from way from the glass
if they don't want to be by that they
can come back you can probably tell
there's a kind of bass sound in air kind
of a white noise sound that's our air
handling our air system is it's quite
extravagant which is also helps to serve
as a noise barrier and then we have
cement with all these walls around the
it's all very very thick cement so we
can even have piano playing out there
and they're not going to hear it
ultimately you know that their needs
have met when they established we've
already had penguin that are laying eggs
in here we already have territories
established and my hand pumping his
chest out sticking his head up in the
air means it is comfortable it's really
interesting thing on this side of the
glass there is friendly to be dominant
personality and so you've had it
actually extraordinary number of births
of young penguin 77 hatch out last year
so what normally at about week three or
four where they're up and walking around
we actually get involved our staff gets
involved and does raising from that
point on the reason that we do the
raising for the parents is because in
the while the parents are being quite a
bit farther away from the water and as
the chicks begin to explore just outside
of the nest they wouldn't fall into the
pool or a fall into the ocean but in
here they have that potential to fall
into the water I'm minimum standards are
based on their overall health do they
get more or are they reproducing are
they living at least as long as they
wouldn't
longer we had our oldest penguin here's
25 thank you my guard penguin
you